we're back man we're definitely just uh
not at the end of the day we are not we
are fresh and we have not recorded we
just got on we just got on here thanks
for having me back um
you're welcome how did you get invited
to the ufc what happened uh this dude
there shout out to gavin
he actually dm me like five years ago
from the ufc account we talked for a bit
and then you know just [ __ ] happens and
then he like followed up with me a
couple weeks ago he's like yo man are
you uh in town we're coming to anaheim i
was like yeah i'm definitely in town
he's like come on out got there and i
was i was ringside what's it like seeing
an actual fight from there from that
distance i mean i see why joe is always
talking about their bodies literally so
many muscles there's literally no other
way you can describe it i mean dude
francis ingano is gigantic i was eyeline
with joe okay that was great really
octagon i was like i see you man i
definitely appreciate what is going on
and you know in a fight but i think the
biggest thing is especially heavyweights
that ring every time they move like the
mats would just thud and you just get
all those extra little nuanced things
where you're like oh [ __ ] it's funny
like ufc fights
you always see the most like random
person not that you random but i'm
saying like someone you'd never expect
no no no no no i'm just saying like it's
like just because of the the camera the
way the camera is on the fighters where
you see like people behind them yeah
like the first like 10 rows yeah and
that's always like the celebrity row
yeah so it's always like you're watching
a fight and you're like is that clay
aiken is that apollo ono
why the [ __ ] is he who does he know yeah
it'd always be like a weird ensemble of
people oh yeah always it'd be like a
women's basketball
pro and then like a bantamweight fighter
yeah and then like maybe you know
[ __ ] um
joel orstein
like that guy watches mma i think i was
row eight but like the side i was on so
they have like the super famous section
right i wasn't there okay okay i was
just like you know ringside ran into a
couple people ran into this comedian uh
rocky dale davis that man in some ways
stole the show he was uh he listened to
the podcast shout out to iraqi he was
hilarious he was drunk and just
screaming there's this guy that kept
standing up in front of us and you know
this is a little bit of a friendly fire
here but he was a shorter man when you
stand up bless his heart man he was just
trying to get he's just trying to see
okay he's gonna see what's going on in
the fight he's stand up and
unfortunately we're all sitting down and
he's blocking our views so rocky being
the big [ __ ] that he is wasted
no time and just saying hey you short
[ __ ] sit down
and at first everyone around
was like
but then as the night kept going and
this dude kept standing up and like
covering key moments there was like
there's these ro this row of dudes
behind us they started getting
frustrated with the guys stand up so
then rocky would get at it and then one
of their guys would be like shut the
[ __ ] down
[Laughter]
and then it just became more people
behind to the point where this dude he
would like think about it three or four
voices would be like don't [ __ ] don't
don't like he'd go to stand up and then
yeah literally just all right no i
wasn't gonna i wasn't gonna stand up
anyways and then he would turn to his
friend he'd be like are they [ __ ] dude
this is [ __ ] pissing me off i just to
stand but he was a short fellow he was a
short fellow oh rocky makes and then i
feel for him i do
as well but i was also like sit the [ __ ]
down rocky made sure that that dude knew
he was small that night oh no you could
say it's mean by the time you stand up
on your ninth or tenth time it was just
like this unspoken thing or everyone
understands yeah we're ringside but
we're all just gonna honor that
we can't see literally the rose are
doing that tick-tock [ __ ] oh so they're
all on the ground yeah there's no like
out like no we're all on one level so
everyone is politely
agreed that if you're in row one you're
gonna stay straight row two you're gonna
all lean to the left row three you're
all gonna lean to the right and we're
just gonna
everyone can see what's going on so if
one person stands it [ __ ] the whole
thing up i mean he stood up as like
people were getting knocked out and i
was like
what the [ __ ] it was so frustrating it
was mean but it wasn't that mean and as
a small person standing next to rocky
i'm not you know i'm not gonna lie i
switched sides i understood part of his
frustration as well because the ufc
brought him out to do
stand up at the weigh-ins i don't want
to take away from his story because it
is his story but damn he sent me a clip
my soul would have been left in pieces
because he bombed i mean yeah like he
was like they weren't expecting stand up
it's like four in the afternoon they're
expecting dudes to stand on the scale
that's it and i was like all the lights
were on huh he's like yep oh jesus and i
was like did they leave the scale up
there for you to walk around it as you
did material and then he showed me in
the live stream of it they didn't mic
the crowd so every time he told a joke
it sounded like
pure silence so the cliff he sent me is
like you know like his closing joke it's
like his big punch line he says it and
he's like [ __ ] y'all man i thought i
would have had y'all uh and then he's
like i'm out of here i mean i'm rocky
dale davis and he leaves and damn so
yeah he he had a hell of a night so
unfortunately the short man had to take
the brunt of it that's fair uh i get it
now i'm on y'all's side now yeah i mean
i also got his you know i ran into
andrew schultz and we chopped it up oh
nice i think i saw him in venice yeah
really briefly yeah he was getting out
of an uber or something like that and i
was like oh i
think that's him tall son of a [ __ ] so
he was there too yeah oh nice yeah he is
tall he's really [ __ ] tall mm-hmm
yeah okay so i did see him you having
fun tonight so far oh yeah most
definitely i had a chat with dana
earlier he said that i could fight any
eight-year-old i want in arlene yeah
we're setting this up yeah have you
picked out an eight-year-old to fight
i'm thinking any like rich toy reviewer
on youtube
the biggest payout
maybe who
well i mean my son jay i'm not gonna say
any names you have to say ryan's toys
watch your back it's also funny because
i think ryan's toys is like he's 10. 16.
now he's 10 okay i was like it's been
he's been eight forever yeah whatever
man that kid's been reviewing toys
forever and they just keep pretending
he's the same age he's like dad i don't
even like these [ __ ] things anymore
can you imagine when he's just reviewing
2016 chain smoking yeah
this is the lego millennium falcon i
don't know dad what's the line ripping
his jewel yeah
you